some songs might speak to your soul even
if you don't know the words the almost
magical way that music reflects and
influences our emotions let the American
poet Henry Wadsworth Longfellow to
declare it the universal language of
mankind but how Universal is it really a
team of more than a dozen researchers
and countless undergraduates set out to
compile and annotate descriptions and
recordings of musical performances
around the world their first finding
music is indeed universal or at least
statistical modeling strongly suggests
that more than 99% of societies have
music then they analyze the song
descriptions for 60 very different
societies from the Pawnee and plains of
North America to the sámi of Scandinavia
a representative sample that let them
test dozens of theories they looked at
different qualities related to song
performance as they classified the songs
they found that three dimensions
accounted for more than a quarter of the
variability between songs
the first was how formal or informal a
song was songs high informality had
large audiences and lots of instruments
often involved ceremonial events and
frequently had adults only audiences in
formal events had smaller audiences
including children or no audience at all
second was how arousing a song was to
its listeners lively events involving
lots of dancing were high on this
dimension while a low value reflected a
calmer event like someone singing to
themselves or a baby last was how
religious a song was songs used in
ceremonies and funerals were high in
religiosity while those without a
spiritual context scored low the
researchers applied their findings to
for widespread categories of music
lullabies dance songs love songs and
healing songs and found clear trends
most dance music was highly arousing
informal but low in religiosity
lullabies were mostly low formality and
low arousal and healing songs cord
flying all the love songs were low in
all dimensions even more interesting the
distribution of these behaviors was
similar in all societies studied next
researchers looked at underlying
acoustic features of a song like tempo
and rhythm they collected 118 recordings
of songs throughout the world
they found two factors that explained a
quarter of the variability in songs
melodic complexity and rhythmic
complexity unsurprisingly dance songs
were more rhythmic since a lullabye but
overall the four categories of songs
couldn't be told apart solely by their
melodica rhythmic complexity scholars
say that their database could fuel
future research into even more
intriguing questions about music
universals and their method might be
used to pick out patterns and other hard
to analyze fields like storytelling or
visual art who knows what other
commonalities underlie the diversity of
cultures around the world
[Music]